-Us talk-show hosts, we throw
around "good friend" a lot,
but you and I, we've known each
other upwards of 20 years.
We are real, actual
good friends.
-We are, and I have to
come clean 'cause I messed up.
-You messed up?
What'd you do, bud?
-Well, I was on
"The Howard Stern Show."
-Uh-huh.
-And he asked me.
He goes, "Who are your best
friends in show business?"
And I said Seth Rogen.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, like,
five seconds after,
I said, "I meant Seth Meyers."
-It took you five seconds?
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Well, I was -- I was drinking.
But I didn't want to go back
and be like,
"No, not Seth Rogen.
I meant Seth Meyers."
Because I'm also friends
with Seth Rogen.
-Yeah.
-Much better friends with you.
-Right.
-I was at your wedding.
-Yeah.
-Wasn't at Seth's.
-Mnh-mnh.
-Would have loved to been.
I didn't make the cut.
-Yeah.
-But you, I did.
So I want to say here and now
that I'm closer friends with you
than I am Seth Rogen.
Screw Seth Rogen.
-I feel like you need
to correct the record
on "Stern" next time you go on.
That's what I'm gonna be...
-He'll watch this, and that
will serve as the correction.
-[ Laughs ] There you go. Hey,
man. Congrats on this movie.
-Thanks, baby.
-We've talked about it already.
It's so wonderful.
You wrote it, you directed it,
you star in it.
And it is about --
It was inspired by the result
of the 2016 election.
-Yes, yes, this movie
would not have been possible
if Hillary Clinton
was president.
-Yeah.
-So thank you to Donald Trump.
-Yup.
-I appreciate it.
Thank you, sir.
-He created jobs.
He gave you --
He created a job.
-He gave me a job.
He gave me a job.
[ Applause ]
And, uh -- He did.
My imitation -- I imitate Trump,
but I realize my imitation
is just your imitation.
-And it's a real
C-minus impression.
-Yours --
So, mine's derivative of that.
It's like a D, but it's j--
[ As President Trump ]
Look, Seth, no, no, no.
[ Normal voice ]
It's that. You know?
-It's really -- I actually
think it's really good.
-You really think it's good?
-You look like you've put
a lot of thought into it.
-Should I take it on the road?
But, yeah,
it was inspired by --
After the 2016 election,
my mother, my brother, and I
got into this huge fight
after dinner about the election,
and we started
kind of pointing fingers,
and we're saying things like,
"It's your fault,"
which was crazy.
But I woke up the next day.
I was like,
"I have to write a movie
about a family fighting
at Thanksgiving."
And here we are.
-And here we are.
And you mentioned your brother.
Your brother, John Barinholtz,
is in the movie
playing your brother,
and he's fantastic, as well.
-Speaking of brothers,
Josh Meyers is in this movie.
-My brother is also
in the movie, yeah.
-That's right. That's right.
-There you go. Family affair.
-There you go.
Keep it in the family, baby.
-And you shot the film --
You shot it all
in Chatsworth, California?
-Chatsworth, California,
is about, oh, 39 minutes
north of L.A.
Fun fact -- the first film
to be shot in Chatsworth
that wasn't pornography.
-Oh, wow.
-I know. It's nice. Right?
Yeah, the mayor came.
-Oh, he must have been so happy.
-He gave us a key to the city
and stuff, and it was crazy.
I shot my movie where,
you know, they shot, you know,
"MILF Hunter 6."
-Oh, wow!
-You know, uh...
-What's their
Planet Hollywood like?
-[ Laughs ]
You don't want to eat there.
-Yeah, yeah.
There's so many MILF pornos.
There's no DILFs.
-No DILFs?
-There's --
You may see the MILF.
"Oh, the MILF, the housewife."
But no one's like --
-That is how I talk about it.
-[ Laughs ]
-"You see, the MILF is..."
-I guess I'm Richard Lewis
from 1989.
But there's no DILFs.
Like, I want to see,
like, a porno that starts off
with a guy, like,
calling DirecTV.
"Why can't I get
the Cowboys game?
Ahh! I'm so horny."
[ Laughter ]
I think I got my next movie.
-You certainly
have act one, yeah.
-You just need one act.
-You do need one act.
-No one makes it past
the second act of a porno.
"I loved it.
It's started off great.
Then in the second act,
I got real tired."